we're on our way to go person shopping
we've got like the main people covered
but there's some other things in depth
again we made Christmas cookies
yesterday I didn't have to look at the
road I would roll my eyes so hard if you
do pity him I would just like everyone
to see how she helped her you bring as
much of your little smudge expensive
lens
[Music]
you
we're heading into the mall very shortly
I brought my drone because there's a lot
of open space here and I thought hey why
not where's the red cop I'm very upset
[Music]
that has a big bag and then you fill it
up all the good
ding-ding-ding-ding-ding the templates
are we can't go to test this or because
I'm in a want one I can't have one
because I will be over constable and
think that it's going to drive for me
and I'm going to hit things because I'm
going to let it dry for
is actually entirely Drive for you yes
this is everything we've been looking
for a dog store cashmere shuttle putting
another in one look at this
it's Steelers Cologne I think he'd like
the big one do you think yeah that was
really so we're gonna get this for
Maddie a nice little chicken and this
for Bobo this is how he looks like he
does what is not good look at this it a
pizza pillow you should get it from Matt
so I've been doing a little bit of
shopping and I'm not doing a good job at
buying my holiday gifts
now we're going to be Apple stores where
I plan to buy most of my present for
someone who I can't say because they
probably watch the video we should get
her a strap good call
where's it at everything about check
this out
SD card with lightning adapter even
though what are we going to do with the
lighting adapter cuz hello USB see is
everything but I can connect my drone
footage to my phone
okay 4k but I do have a USBC adapter
baby into majora we're going to fly it
around the mall my goodness we got a
peppermint bark cheesecake at the
Cheesecake Factory I never actually get
cheesecake after juicing factories what
today is the day this pepper I'm not
gonna start it in here yeah but what if
it malfunctions you know nothing
remember how many drones you actually
like pull into the house put your jacket
on you idiot I'm just feeling a lot of
it if you hold this real quick it's not
gonna do anything that's a gamble no I
think this little drone flying it mall
oh this car pulls up right next to her
thank you
[Music]
see where John Dingell is closed or I
can't go to the morgue because I might
have to get out oh and flying over
Macy's right now now what time is the
Cheesecake Factory on opposite side of
where we are I think it was over here
line go back
and next one drunk like parking ticket
looks very good not like wow this is
some riveting content but we flew it now
we're going to shine eagle I plan on
doing 12 days of Christmas vlogs and
then I realized Christmas is like now so
that didn't happen so I'm sorry gift
cards and pretzels
Merry Christmas Wow look at that huge
bone Maddy would love it ah camo sweater
oh my goodness let the camo thank you
but that's it we got something here for
you honey
what is that present the little chickens
turkey so he likes it look we got bow we
got chewy Vuitton first
it's like a kosher butcher Janet Scotia
Jenna won't get that one oh look at your
person a tea doing some very important
Christmas matters you guys ready
I have upload my Christmas video because
our internet at home does not work I
made Jenna download it while she's at a
friend's house what took me five hours
ago and ended up not even worth more so
she had to download it for me okay let's
go to Starbucks and upload baby
[Music]
mom go on watch here's the
problem nobody please Pokemon go anymore
like you guys are five months too late
just spend and Christmas Eve it's the
Midas Auto Center
something's wrong with grease car who
wants to take a bet the batteries long
even the probable very very small
battery dead where it - - touch I'm not
your little Christmas cheer thank you I
survived in the paper hanging with
Christmas cheer yes you would zero
Christian have a holly jolly Christmas -
the best job oh oh yeah
I don't know jingle bell jingle bell
Jingle Bell Rock jingle bell time and
jingle bell wine discussion my pants are
long enough this is like weird bigger
boots or longer pan
we just had the wildest snapchat story
of all time in Midas we got a Christmas
miracle hmm
is it raining I don't think so
[Music]
oh it's so cool
so it's Christmas Eve we're about to
have Christmas dinner and I asked you
guys on Twitter what shirt I should wear
it was a toss-up between the one that
I'm wearing my Star Wars Christmas
letter or at my Mario Christmas
sweatshirt since this one one it looks
like my Mario sweatshirt will be worn
tomorrow for Christmas we're about to
have Christmas Eve dinner so let's go
make myself up my Christmas Eve dinner
plate and I'll take you guys with me
along brush this evening Sarah will be
here so soon
[Music]
Jenna Merry Christmas Eve - I'm not
wearing anything festive it's okay
everything on this table interests me
yes yes yes yes tell Maddie come here
you on eggy that's a good sit sit baby
oh you're already sitting okay hey come
Oh Christmas meal look at this delicious
cake grandma would you make this cake
cremated Wow
there's your apples from your debts at
temple trees Wow
mmm definitely dude like an apple from
the backyard he missed him so much
oh I think I'm gonna fly my drone right
now
[Music]
great work great what it's uh it's dark
and cold out look at our beautiful
matching pajamas that we have for
tomorrow thank you mommy
if you dad I know you went out shopping
yes I felt the cold hey what have you
guys have a very Merry Christmas because
today is Christmas although right now
it's complete Christmas Eve so I will
see you guys in the next video
Merry Christmas Happy New Year's happy
holidays happy all of the things
good bye what you seen you're the best
Baker of them all how many freakin
cookies am i making am i making it for
all of the elves and all the reindeer -
I won't say enough to be a happy man
really creepy one tist
what did you say - again I was listening
to myself talk looks good to me
is this not something else